à l'occasion du réaménagement du my des
saules la sauce régal se mobilisent pour
faire entendre sa voix l'association qui
fait la promotion de l'agriculture
urbaine souhaite que la mairie créé des
jardins partagés desjardins qui selon
eux permettront d'améliorer la vie au
quartier des soldes mais nous on
aimerait bien implantée dans deux
parades a par endroits des endroits des
potagers qu'on puisse surtout en fait
cultiver avec les gens parce que notre
idée c'est à la fois de lutter contre le
réchauffement climatique c'est-à-dire de
proposer des légumes locaux accessibles
aux gens avant tout c'est pour leur
propre consommation est aussi retrouver
du lien social dans un univers un petit
peu anonyme comme celui ci on aurait un
peu comme dans les villages quoi une
trentaine de personnes s'étaient
rassemblés pour l'événement et ils sont
séduits par cette idée de jardins
partagés j'ai signé le registre j'ai mis
un petit mot en fait j'aimerais bien
avoir des débats dans lesquels on
pourrait planter des légumes des petites
choses des fraisiers des choses simples
à cultiver ensemble et à partager et
puis aussi pourquoi pas des herbes
aromatiques chose qui pousse tout seul
très souvent très simples à cultiver moi
j'adore jardiner alors que j'ai pas de
jardin et j'adorais aussi des arbres ce
métier l'association du jardin partagé
de guyancourt sem qui peut a aussi
participé à l'événement le my des saules
va entamer sa transformation à partir de
l'été prochain